Florida man remains behind bars nearly
two years after his murder conviction
was overturned
crosley Green has been in prison for
three decades for a crime he says he did
not commit while a federal judge
overturned his conviction his freedom
depends on a decision from the US Court
of Appeals Erin Moriarty investigates
for this week's 48 hours she's followed
this case for more than 20 years on
march 12 2020 Crossley greens attorneys
took on the state of florida in front of
the US Court of Appeals let me tear
mustard to the core system nearly two
years ago a federal court overturned
greens conviction for the murder of chip
Flynn Flynn was found shot in a Florida
citrus grove on april 4th 1989 after
Flynn's
ex-girlfriend Kim Hallett called 9-1-1
to report a shooting Brevard County
deputy sheriff Mark brixi and Sergeant
Diane Clark responded to the call
something is not ringing true he didn't
feel right
chip Flynn was bleeding from a single
gunshot wound to his chest and later
died
Kim Hallett claimed a black man had
robbed and shot him you don't see
anybody else around you don't see any
shell casing and it just makes you
wonder it's unfortunately a classic case
of what is often referred to as a racial
hoax which is a black guy did it
brixi and Clark met with them prosecutor
Christopher white I told him I thought
she did it white spoke with us in 2015 I
don't see how there's anything here
concrete to tell anybody that Kim
Halleck lied mark and Dianne suspect the
girl did it
White's notes from his meeting with
Rickey and Clark were never turned over
to greens defense I knew immediately
that this was a game changer and it was
it's what convinced the federal court to
overturn greens conviction his attorneys
now hope that the US Court of Appeals
will affirm that ruling
what's the best case here the court
rules in our favor at that point we
would move for Crosby's immediate
release from prison I'm just hoping and
praying that day comes soon and Erin
Moriarty joins us now good morning Erin
when is the court expected to rule on
greens case and and we heard a little
bit the best case scenario what's the
worst case for him well Anthony what's
really lucky here is that he got his
oral arguments on March 12th before the
country shut down and so there is a good
chance that he's going to get a ruling
within three to six months that's what
his attorneys are hoping for but can I
just point out why I have stuck with
this case so long and why it's important
his attorneys allege the Crosley Green
is in prison because of a racial hoax
that his prosecution and his conviction
happened because a witness said a black
eye did it and our reporting tomorrow
really supports that and clearly that
should not be happy in this country so
the worst case in this of course is that
the US Court of Appeals will agree with
the state of Florida and and rule
against him and he will stay in prison
all right Erin Moriarty thanks Erin you
can see Erin's report crossly Green's
hard time tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS